This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Good evening. A historic day at Stormant after two years of talks and after a generation of bloodshed and decades of division and acrimony, a new era of peace. In 1998, political leaders in Northern Ireland signed a peace agreement. They hoped it would end the sectarian violence between Catholics and Protestants, who'd been fighting each other for decades. At the root of the conflict was the question of whether Northern Ireland should reunite with the rest of Ireland, or whether it should remain part of the United Kingdom.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。晚上好。在经历了两年多的谈判、一代人的流血冲突以及长达数十年的分裂与敌意之后，斯托蒙特迎来了历史性的一天，这是一个和平的新时代。1998年，北爱尔兰的政治领导人们签署了一项和平协议。他们希望这能结束天主教徒和新教徒之间长达数十年的宗派暴力。冲突的根源在于北爱尔兰是应该与爱尔兰其余地区重新统一，还是应该继续作为英国的一部分。
That's Gagurian, he's the creator of the Far From Home podcast. Most Catholics were nationalists, meaning they wanted to govern themselves as part of a united Ireland. Most Protestants were loyalists, also called unionists, who felt the stronger allegiance to the British crown. Paramilitaries on both sides had carried out kidnappings, bombings, and assassinations. More than 3,000 people had died. But the peace accord aimed to end that violence. Well, I look forward equally to a new era of friendship and reconciliation
那是加古里安，他是播客《远离家园》的创作者。大多数天主教徒是民族主义者，这意味着他们希望作为统一的爱尔兰的一部分来管理自己。大多数新教徒是保皇派，也被称为统一派，他们对英国王室有着更强烈的忠诚。双方的准军事组织都曾实施过绑架、爆炸和暗杀。已有3000多人丧生。但和平协议旨在结束这种暴力。嗯，我同样期待一个充满友谊和和解的新时代
between unionists and nationalists, in which each tradition can learn truly the value of the other. That was more than 20 years ago, and while the political situation in Northern Ireland is certainly better today, it's hard to say that friendship and reconciliation are the norm. Northern Ireland remains divided. In some cases quite literally. So on your left you can see the wall. The big brick wall. Yeah. So here we have a physical interface that separates two communities. Okay. This is Ian McLaughlin. He's part of the Lower Shankil Community Association,
在统一派和民族主义者之间，每个传统都能真正了解彼此的价值。那是20多年以前的事了，虽然北爱尔兰今天的政治局势无疑有所改善，但很难说友谊和和解已成为常态。北爱尔兰依然处于分裂状态。在某些情况下可以说是字面意义上的分裂。所以，在你的左边你可以看到这堵墙。那堵大砖墙。是的。所以在这里我们有一个物理分界线，将两个社区隔开。好的。这位是伊恩·麦克劳克林。他是下尚克尔社区协会的成员，
which works to improve conditions in his neighborhood. He took me on a tour of Belfast, northern Ireland's capital city, where he lives and works. The wall that we are at now is called the Meldenbreg wall, because there's exactly a million bricks in them. You have a Protestant community on your left, and you have a Catholic community on your right. There are so many walls like this in Belfast, which physically separate Protestant neighborhoods from Catholic ones. Ian showed me short walls and tall walls, some are more like fences that you could see through, while others are made of bricks and steel. Many have clearly been reinforced over time, a cinder block wall topped with corrugated iron topped with razor wire stretching up towards the sky.
该协会致力于改善他所在社区的状况。他带我参观了北爱尔兰首都贝尔法斯特，他就在那里生活和工作。我们现在所在的这堵墙被称为米尔登堡墙，因为里面正好有一百万块砖。你的左边是新教徒社区，右边是天主教徒社区。贝尔法斯特有许多这样的墙，它们将新教徒社区和天主教徒社区在物理上隔离开来。伊恩给我看了矮墙和高墙，有些更像是可以看透的栅栏，而另许多则是用砖块和钢材建造的。许多墙随着时间推移显然都被加固了，煤渣砖墙顶部铺着波纹铁皮，再往上是直插云霄的铁丝网。
Here we have the Protestant community on the left, head and behind a security wall with Mattel fans. There's even a wall right near Ian's house. So I live here. Is this where you grew up? Yeah. Could we perhaps get out in a year or a moment? Is that okay?
在这里，左边是新教徒社区，位于安全墙的后方，配有金属风扇。甚至在伊恩家附近就有一堵墙。所以我就住在这里。这是你长大的地方吗？是的。我们也许能出去一会儿吗？可以吗？
It's a tidy neighborhood of modest brick homes. Two blocks away, the street dead ends at a combination wall and fence that's 30 feet tall. Ian explains it's been there ever since 1972 when he was 11 years old. So do you remember when this wall went up? Like do you have clear memories of when they were building it? Oh yeah years old. So do you remember when this wall went up, like do you have clear memories of when they were building it? Oh yeah, yeah. What do you remember?
这是一个整洁的社区，有着简朴的砖砌房屋。两个街区之外，这条街到头是一堵高达30英尺的组合墙和栅栏。伊恩解释说，它从1972年就已经在那里了，当时他11岁。那么你还记得这堵墙是什么时候建起来的吗？比如，对于他们建造这堵墙的时候，你有没有清晰的记忆？哦，是的，好几岁了。所以你还记得这堵墙是什么时候建起来的吗？比如，对于他们建造这堵墙的时候，你有没有清晰的记忆？哦，是的，是的。你还记得什么？
Well, I remember that you had almost a 24 hour constant military or police presence in these streets because at that time, the opportunity to engage and physical violence presented itself every day and every night because there was no physical barrier between people. So that's why the things were created in the first sentence. It was designed to prevent physical interaction. In Northern Ireland, there seems to be a euphemism for everything. The walls are called peace lines. The neighborhoods they cut through are called interface areas.
嗯，我记得这些街道上几乎24小时都有源源不断的军队或警察驻守，因为在那个时候，由于人们之间没有物理屏障，参与肢体暴力的机会每天每夜都在发生。这就是为什么最初会设立这些东西。它的设计就是为了阻止物理互动。在北爱尔兰，似乎每件事都有一个委婉的说法。这些墙被称为和平墙。它们穿过的社区被称为交界地区。
And the period when many of the walls went up was a violent time in the 1970s and 80s that everybody just calls the troubles. Decades later, you'd think the walls would have come down, but they haven't. Almost all of the walls remain. They cut across communities like monuments to the conflict etched into the physical landscape and removing them isn't going to be easy. It could be that perhaps at one of these barriers or structures you lost a love one, you lost a husband or a partner or a brother and you have never had closure for that.
许多墙建起来的那个时期是20世纪70至80年代一个暴力的时代，大家通常称之为“冲突时期”（The Troubles）。几十年过去了，你可能会认为这些墙早该拆除了，但它们并没有。几乎所有的墙都保留了下来。它们横穿各个社区，就像刻在自然地貌上的冲突纪念碑，要拆除它们并非易事。可能在其中的某一道屏障或建筑旁，你失去了挚爱，失去了丈夫、伴侣或兄弟，而你从未真正释怀。
So that that event that happened 40 or 42 years ago, it may as well have happened four years ago for some people because they live yesterday, every day, every day, every day. The Irish conflict goes back hundreds of years and it can be tough to pinpoint exactly when it began. But for our purposes, let's begin this history lesson in 1922. That's when after decades demands for self-governance and a bloody guerrilla war, Ireland gained its independence from the UK with its capital in Dublin. Around the same time, the island was partitioned with six counties in the north remaining part of the United Kingdom,
所以，对于某些人来说，40或42年前发生的那个事件，就好像是四年前发生的一样，因为他们每天、每天、每天都生活在昨天。爱尔兰的冲突可以追溯到数百年前，要准确指出它是什么时候开始的可能会很困难。但为了我们的目的，让我们从1922年开始这堂历史课。正是在那时，经历了数十年的自治诉求和血腥的游击战后，爱尔兰脱离英国赢得了独立，其首都在都柏林。大约在同一时期，该岛被分割，北部的六个郡继续留在联合王国境内，
forming northern Ireland. Protestant loyalists were the majority there, and they went about creating a social and political framework to make sure they remained in power. A framework that much of the Catholic population found inherently unfair and even discriminatory. You couldn't vote if you didn't own your own property, own a business, but then you couldn't get access to business and property if you didn't get access to money, and you couldn't get access to your business and property. If you didn't get access to money and you couldn't get access to money,
组成了北爱尔兰。新教保皇派在那里占多数，他们着手建立一个社会和政治框架，以确保他们继续掌权。很大一部分天主教人口发现这个框架本质上是不公平的，甚至是带有歧视性的。如果你不拥有自己的财产、不经营企业，你就不能投票，但如果你没有资金来源，你就无法获得企业和财产，如果你没有资金来源，你就无法获得企业和财产，如果你没有资金，你就无法获得资金，
if you couldn't get a job, you couldn't get a job necessarily because you were a Catholic. Johnny Bern is a senior lecturer at Ulster University. So, you know, Catholics didn't have senior positions in the civil service, for example, then get access necessarily to further education and they couldn't change the system because they couldn't vote in people from the particular background that they came from. Though the two groups lived close to each other, it was like they were in totally different worlds. Here's Ian McLaughlin again.
如果你找不到工作，你就不一定能找到工作，仅仅因为你是个天主教徒。强尼·伯恩是阿尔斯特大学的高级讲师。所以，你知道，例如天主教徒在公务员队伍中没有高级职位，不一定能获得继续教育的机会，他们无法改变这个体制，因为他们无法选出代表他们特定背景的人。尽管这两个群体生活得很近，但感觉就像身处完全不同的世界。这里又是伊恩·麦克劳克林。
I had no interaction whatsoever with kids from a Catholic background, no. Protestant families like Ian sent their kids to the state run schools, while Catholic children mostly attended schools run by the church, and each group usually lived in separate neighborhoods with people of their own kind. Well, the communities had their own men and the infrastructures. You had your own shops, you had your own skills at all times. Which meant that Catholics and Protestants could live their whole lives without really knowing
我和天主教背景的孩子没有任何互动，完全没有。像伊恩这样新教徒家庭把孩子送去州立学校，而天主教儿童大多上教会开办的学校，每个群体通常和自己人住在不同的社区里。嗯，这些社区有他们自己的人员和基础设施。你随时都有自己的商店，有自己的学校。这意味着天主教徒和新教徒可以过完一生，却完全不认识
anyone from the other community. This segregation meant sectarian divides just got deeper and deeper. My grandparents were very, very melatoninous and anti-catholic. And Ian still remembers some of the things they used to say. You know, this is what we're always going to have in the countryside with these people. We need to drive them into the sea. I suppose the alarming thing today, I want to think about it, was that they actually meant it.
来自另一个社区的任何人。这种隔离意味着宗派分裂越来越深。我的祖父母非常非常排外并且反天主教。伊恩仍然记得他们过去常说的一些话。你知道，我们在乡下永远得面对这些家伙。我们需要把他们赶进海里去。我想今天令人警惕的是，当我想到这一点时，他们当时是认真的。
They physically meant that. Drive these people into the sea. How can you live here with these people? Those kinds of anti-Catholic attitudes had real and serious effects on people's lives. Well, I remember the first job I've been able to do it now, played for. This is Joe O'Donnell.
他们真心的意思是。把这些人赶进海里。你怎么能和这些人住在一起？那种反天主教的态度对人们的生活产生了真实而严重的影響。嗯，我记得我能做的第一份工作，申请过。这是乔·奥唐纳。
He grew up in a Catholic nationalist household Well, I remember the first job application I applied for. This is Joo Donnell. He grew up in a Catholic nationalist household and he considered himself Irish, not British. And on that first job application he filled out, it asked for his nationality. I wrote down Irish and my mother was reading over the job application and she says, you better change that, you never get that job. And she was right, I didn't. By the late 1960s, the list of Catholic grievances had gotten pretty long. Not only were they discriminated against an employment, they didn't have equal access to public housing and gerrymandering reduced their political influence.
他在一个天主教民族主义家庭长大，嗯，我记得我申请的第一份工作。这是乔·奥唐纳。他在一个天主教民族主义家庭长大，他认为自己是爱尔兰人，而不是英国人。在他填写的 pierwszej 第一份求职申请表上，询问了他的国籍。我写下了爱尔兰人，我母亲正看着这份求职申请说，你最好改一下，你永远得不到那份工作。她是对的，我确实没得到。到了20世纪60年代末，天主教徒的不满清单已经变得相当长。他们不仅在就业上受到歧视，在公共住房方面也无法获得平等待遇，而且划区不公（Gerrymandering）削弱了他们的政治影响力。
But their demands for change were met with strong and sometimes violent loyalist resistance. So, after being frustrated with the slow pace of progress, they began to protest in the streets. But change wouldn't come easily to Northern Ireland. The police responded to the marches with arrests and imprisonments, which only made the protests grow larger. Eventually, the protests turned into riots, which in turn sparked more riots. Especially in urban areas like Belfast, Catholics and Protestants live right on top of each other, making the situation even more explosive.
但他们对变革的要求遇到了强烈的、有时甚至是暴力的保皇派抵抗。因此，在对进展缓慢感到沮丧之后，他们开始走上街头抗议。但变革不会轻易降临北爱尔兰。警方对游行采取了逮捕和监禁的回应，这反而使抗议规模越来越大。最终，抗议演变成了骚乱，进而引发了更多的骚乱。尤其是在像贝尔法斯特这样的城市地区，天主教徒和新教徒紧邻居住，使得局势更加一触即发。
I can recall various incidents as a young jail. Ian McLaughlin remembers going to a shop with his mom. Someone came in and said, you have 10 minutes to get out of the shop. As a kid, I turned around, so two guys, Bella Clevver's on, and one of them had a gun on the other, and they were set a bomb on the table.
我能回忆起小时候发生的各种事件。伊恩·麦克劳克林记得和妈妈一起去商店。有人进来对他们说，你们有10分钟的时间离开这家商店。作为一个孩子，我回过头，看到两个家伙戴着巴拉克拉法帽，其中一个人手里拿着枪指着另一个人，他们正在桌上放置一枚炸弹。
I'm within five minutes, that shop just blew up around everybody, so I mean, killings were happening at a very rapid rate, and it was almost an everyday occurrence. In Belfast, the British Army is once again back in the old routine, men in the middle, keeping peace between two warring factions. But this time, it's not Aiden, Cyprus, or some far off colony. It is incredibly in Britain's own backyard, northern island. By 1969, the British military was dispatched to Belfast to maintain order, but many people had already started taking matters into their own hands. Residents in Ian's neighborhood of Shankill started building makeshift barricades between the two communities.
不到五分钟，那家商店就在所有人身边炸毁了，所以我的意思是，谋杀案以非常快的速度在发生，而且几乎成了日常事件。在贝尔法斯特，英国军队再次回到了老常规中，居中調停，在两个交战派系之间維持和平。但这一次，不是在亚丁、塞浦路斯或某个遥远的殖民地。它令人难以置信地发生在英国自己的后院——北爱尔兰。到1969年，英国军队被派往贝尔法斯特维持秩序，但许多人已经开始自己动手解决问题。伊恩所在的尚克尔社区的居民开始在两个社区之间建造临时路障。
They used burnt out cars, construction debris, rubble from vacant houses, and basically whatever materials they could find to protect themselves from the other side. Finally after a summer of unrest, Northern Ireland's Prime Minister had had enough. On September 9, 1969, Major James Chichester Clark went on television and made an announcement. We have now decided that the Army will erect and man a firm peace line to be sighted between the Divis Street area and the Shankil Road on a line determined by a representative body from the city hall. By firm peace line, he meant that the army would dismantle the barriers the residents had built and replace them with a more official looking 5-foot tall barbed wire fence.
他们用烧毁的汽车、建筑废料、空置房屋的瓦砾，以及基本上能找到的任何材料来保护自己免受另一方的袭击。终于，在经历了一个动荡的夏天后，北爱尔兰首相再也忍无可忍了。1969年9月9日，詹姆斯·奇切斯特-克拉克少将（Major James Chichester Clark）上电视发表了声明。我们现在决定，军队将在迪维斯街区和尚克尔路之间建立并派驻一条坚固的和平线，这条线由市议会的代表机构确定的路线划分。他所说的坚固和平线，是指军队将拆除居民们建造的障碍物，取而代之的是看起来更官方的、5英尺高的带刺铁丝网栅栏。
Construction began the following day. The army moved in to build their peace line on the site of the Protestant Barricade, work proceeded smoothly. The Shankhil peace line was meant to be a strictly temporary measure. The thinking was that the barrier would give people on both sides a chance to cool down and stop the violence. One British Army major predicted that the fence would be gone by Christmas. But things didn't go quite according to plan.
建设工作于次日开始。军队进驻并在新教徒路障的旧址上修建他们的和平线，工作进展顺利。尚克尔和平线原本只是一项严格的临时措施。当时的设想是，这道屏障将给双方一个冷静下来并停止暴力的机会。一名英国陆军少将预测，这个栅栏到圣诞节就会消失。但事情并没有完全按计划进行。
Instead of being removed, that barbed wire fence was later replaced with corrugated iron sheeting that was twice as high, and the army even added observation posts and floodlights. Ten months later, the army put up a second iron wall between two neighborhoods in North Belfast, again insisting that it was just a temporary measure. But it turned out, things were just getting started. Here's Luxford Johnny Bern again. So the whole plan was to get the communities to talk and the anti-start taking the walls down. But then what happened was we normalized the policy. From 1969 onwards our response
那道带刺铁丝网栅栏不仅没有被拆除，后来还被换成了高出一倍的波纹铁皮，军队甚至还增设了观察哨和泛光灯。十个月后，军队在北贝尔法斯特的两个社区之间修建了第二道铁墙，再次坚称这只是一项临时措施。但事实证明，事情才刚刚开始。这里又是拉克斯福德的强尼·伯恩。所以整个计划是让社区进行对话，并开始拆除这些墙。但随后发生的事情是我们使这种政策常态化了。从1969年开始，我们对
to violence, the threat of violence, was physical segregation. Even as the walls went up, the fighting continued. And as the fighting continued, the response was to build more walls. They were an imperfect solution, but burn things they probably prevented things from being even worse. The reality is, I don't support it, but segregation works. If you have got two communities who live feet apart. With members of them who are threatening to kill each other, who both feel vulnerable, who
暴力以及暴力威胁的应对方式就是物理隔离。甚至在这些墙建起来的同时，战斗仍在继续。随着战斗的继续，应对之策就是建造更多的墙。它们是一个不完美的解决方案，但伯恩认为它们可能确实阻止了事情变得更糟。现实情况是，我不支持它，但隔离确实有效。如果你有两个相距仅几尺的社区。其中有成员扬言要杀死对方，双方都感到脆弱，
both feel fearful, who are asking the state to do something in response, then a physical will limits the opportunities for both communities to meet each other and to engage in violence and disorder. Over the next two decades, the government and private landowners constructed close to a hundred additional barriers in communities across Northern Ireland. Ian remembers how they started sprouting up everywhere. You know, the state didn't publicly advertise for plan permission, they're acting structures, they just went and put these structures in place.
双方都感到恐惧，并要求国家采取行动作为回应，那么一堵物理墙就限制了两个社区相互会面以及参与暴力和混乱的机会。在接下来的二十年里，政府和私人土地所有者在北爱尔兰各地的社区额外修建了近百道屏障。伊恩记得它们是如何开始到处涌现的。你知道，国家并没有公开发布规划许可广告，他们只是在修建建筑，径直将这些结构搭建起来。
So you could have quite literally driven down or walked down a street one day and the following one day you went back to it there was a structure across the street preventing you from doing the same thing. One wall even ran through the center of a city park in Duncarn, a formerly dangerous neighborhood of North Belfast. As far as I know it's the only park certainly in Europe that has a peace fence around a sort of segregation barrier. Here in Shannon grew up nearby in a Catholic nationalist home. The wall is made of corrugated steel
所以你可能有一天开车或步行走过一条街，第二天再回到那里时，街上就横亘着一个阻碍你通行的建筑。有一堵墙甚至穿过了邓卡恩（Duncarn）一个城市公园的中心，那是北贝尔法斯特一个曾经很危险的社区。据我所知，它肯定是欧洲唯一一个在某种隔离屏障周围建有和平栅栏的公园。这里的香农在附近的一个天主教民族主义家庭长大。这堵墙由波纹钢制成
and covered with graffiti and it kind of snakes up and down this grass covered hill. And it basically cuts the park into where we understand the development of it. This would be regarded as the Catholic the state. The other side of the fence would be regarded as the Protestant union, as a one part. Finally, in 1994, it seemed like all the violence and wall building might finally subside. The provisional Irish Republican Army released a statement agreeing to lay down their weapons. A cassette of the statement was also handed over. We are there for a dream, a new situation,
上面涂满了涂鸦，它顺着这片长满青草的山丘蜿蜒起伏。它基本上把公园一分为二，据我们理解其发展历程，这里将被视为天主教的地盘。栅栏的另一边将被视为新教统一派的地盘。最后，在1994年，所有的暴力和筑墙行为似乎终于可以平息了。临时爱尔兰共和军发表声明，同意放下武器。该声明的磁带也被交了出去。我们因此迎来了一个梦想，一个新的局面，
and a spirit of determination and confidence. They promised to shift their tactics to political negotiation. The announcement was met with a mixed of skepticism and celebration. Many people in Northern Ireland felt it was a historic development. Which is what makes that wall here and showed be in the park all the more remarkable. Because there's one thing I failed to mention. Do you remember when this wall was put up here? Yeah, it's an amazing day for people to remember
以及一种决心和自信的精神。他们承诺将战术转向政治谈判。这一宣布受到了怀疑与庆祝交织的反应。北爱尔兰的许多人认为这是一个历史性的发展。这也是为什么公园里的那堵墙和秀显得更加引人注目。因为有一件事我漏掉了。你还记得这堵墙是什么时候建在这里的吗？是的，这是一个令人惊叹的日子，人们都记得
because it was the first of September 1994. It was one more start of them. That day they sign up because on the 31st of August, 1994, the day before, was the day that the IRA and I stood in a fire. That's right. This wall was built after the ceasefire. I guess people would hear this story and they would think that's unusual that the ceasefire was signed but then the very next day a new wall is erected. Does that seem strange at all to you?
因为它是一九九四年九月一日。那是他们开始的又一天。那天他们签署了协议，因为在1994年8月31日，也就是前一天，是爱尔兰共和军宣布停火的日子。没错了。这堵墙是在停火协议签署后建造的。我想人们听到这个故事会觉得很不寻常，停火协议刚刚签署，紧接着第二天就竖起了一堵新墙。你觉得这不是很奇怪吗？
The contacts of the time, it was, you know, because the betterness between the two sides of our community was still there, almost still manifest themselves on the streets. A few years later, in 1998, the troubles officially ended with the signing of the peace agreement, but that didn't stop even more walls and fences from going up. At the interfaces between Catholic and Protestant communities, the same old tensions remained. The most recent fence was built in 2013. Eventually, the government enacted an official policy of wall removal. They even set a target of 2023. But when you talk to people on the ground, there seems to be widespread agreement that the
当时的背景是，你知道的，因为我们社区双方之间的敌意依然存在，几乎仍然在街头显现出来。几年后的1998年，随着和平协议的签署，“冲突时期”正式结束，但这并没有阻止更多墙壁和栅栏的修建。在天主教和新教社区的交界处，老旧的紧张关系依然存在。最近的一道栅栏建于2013年。最终，政府颁布了一项拆墙的官方政策。他们甚至设定了2023年的目标。但是当你与当地人交谈时，似乎普遍认为这个
target is completely unrealistic. And it's not even clear if most people want the walls to come down. One of the newer walls sits in the whitewell neighborhood of North Belfast. It runs right through Joe Hughes' backyard. Joe has been surrounded by violence for much of his life. He recalls being a kid and hiding under his bed while gunshots rang out in the streets. His family moved at one point in search of safety, but the new neighborhood was even worse. So after he and his wife got married, they moved yet again to a new house in a new development,
目标完全是不切实际的。而且甚至不清楚大多数人是否真的希望拆除这些墙。其中一堵较新的墙坐落在北贝尔法斯特的怀特韦尔（Whitewell）社区。它直接穿过了乔·休斯（Joe Hughes）的后院。乔的大部分人生都被暴力所包围。他回忆起自己还是个孩子的时候，躲在床底下，听着街上枪声大作。他的家人为了寻找安全曾搬过一次家，但新社区甚至更糟。因此，他和妻子结婚后，又一次搬到了新开发区的新房子里，
and it seemed like finally the situation would improve. There was a lot to look forward to. So there was a spezi in the area being newly built and being mixed. Mixed meaning a place where people of different backgrounds lived together, which was perfect since Joe's Catholic and his wife is Protestant. Their hope was that they could start over with a clean slate in an area that didn't have the sectarian baggage of other places that they lived in the past, and they were hoping to raise their daughters in a non-parison environment. When we were all for that, you know, as a way forward, to bring them up, we wanted them
局面似乎终于要改善了。有很多值得期待的事情。所以那个区域有一个新修建的、属于混合型的空间。混合的意思是不同背景的人生活在一起的地方，这非常完美，因为乔是天主教徒，而他的妻子是新教徒。他们希望能够在一个没有他们过去生活过的地方那种宗派包袱的区域重新开始，他们希望能在一个非宗派的环境中抚养女儿。我们都全力支持这一点，你知道的，作为一种前进的方式，把她们抚养长大，我们希望她们
to be able to go anywhere they wanted, and not be held back because of religion and begotry and stuff, which we, um, but didn't like, because we've never brought up like ourselves, you know. But after four or five years, things got bad again. It was the mid-2000s by now, years after peace had been declared, but summertime violence began to flare up once more. First Joe's neighbor was attacked, and then he says another incident hit even closer to home. It was nearly midnight, totally dark. Joe and his wife were in bed. The next thing we were walking by the barn and that smashed the bottles, and the bricks
能够去任何她们想去的地方，而不受宗教和顽固偏见等事情的阻挠，这些是我们，嗯，并不喜欢的，因为我们自己从来没有那样被抚养长大，你知道的。但在四五年后，情况又变坏了。当时已经是2000年代中期，也就是和平宣布多年之后，但夏天的暴力活动再次开始爆发。先是乔的邻居遭到袭击，接着他说另一起事件更加接近他的家。当时快半夜了，一片漆黑。乔和他的妻子在床上。接下来发生的事是有人从谷仓旁走过，砸碎了酒瓶，还有砖块
and getting fired at the windows and stuff. Three Molotov cocktails, or petrol bombs, as Joe called them, slammed into his back wall. Within minutes, his house was engulfed in flames. Joe began to seriously question whether he and his family should leave. He had always been opposed to peace walls in the past. He says he didn't understand them, and he felt they did more harm than good. But now that he had kids, he saw things differently. In the end, it was the construction
向窗户砸来之类的。三个莫洛托夫鸡尾酒（也就是乔所说的汽油弹）砸在他家的后墙上。几分钟之内，他的房子就被大火吞没了。乔开始认真考虑他和家人是否应该离开。他过去一直反对和平墙。他说他理解不了这些墙，觉得它们带来的害处多于好处。但现在他有了孩子，他的看法就不同了。最后，是建造
of a two-story tall mesh fence that convinced Joe and many of his neighbors that it was safe enough to stay. This peace wall that we have, it's not intruding on on anyone, and it's not ugly and on a cheaper form. What it does is give us peace of mind. It's not intrudent on anyone and it's not ugly and on each year performed. What it does is give us peace of mind. It's important that people do have security. Joe says almost all the people on his block supported this wall at the time it was built and the vast majority continued to support it today. Even though Joe says there hasn't been any more violence in the 12 years since it went
一座两层楼高的铁丝网栅栏，让乔和他的许多邻居确信呆在这里足够安全。我们拥有的这堵和平墙，它没有侵扰任何人，它也不丑陋，而且是一种更便宜的形式。它所做的是给我们带来内心的平静。它没有侵扰任何人，它也不丑陋，而且是一种更便宜的形式。它所做的是给我们带来内心的平静。人们拥有安全感是很重要的。乔说，他的街区几乎所有人在修建这堵墙时都给予了支持，绝大多数人今天仍然支持它。尽管乔说自它建起后的12年里再没有发生过任何暴力事件，但他认为这正是它需要留在原地的原因。
up, he thinks that's precisely why it needs to remain where it is. The people in the straight of sort of say, I don't want to take them down, they can sleep and they're bad at night, they're still worried about when the next attack's come from. Take it over. Yeah. Can I check, can you buy it? This is what you get by the way, Scott. But not everyone thinks more walls are a good idea. Just down the hill from Joe in the Whitewell neighborhood, Geraldine O'Cain is looking for ways to create a community without them.
街上的人基本上会说，我不想拆掉它们，他们晚上可以睡个好觉，他们依然担心下一次袭击什么时候会从天而降。接过去。是的。我能查一下，你能买吗？顺便说一句，斯科特，这就是你得到的。但并不是每个人都认为建更多的墙是个好主意。就在怀特韦尔社区乔的住处下坡不远处，杰拉丁·奥凯恩（Geraldine O'Cain）正在寻找建立一个没有墙的社区的方法。
She works for an organization that's trying to build connections between young people from Protestant and Catholic backgrounds. The whole idea, she says, is that it's hard to throw a stone at a friend. But her work has sometimes made her a target. Six years ago, someone snuck into the building where she works with the kids and left an explosive device in the courtyard. A bomb disposal team got rid of it. But if the young ones had been in on time,
她在一家致力于在来自新教和天主教背景的年轻人之间建立联系的组织工作。她说，整个想法就是，朝朋友扔石头是很难的。但她的工作有时让她成为了攻击目标。六年前，有人潜入她和孩子们工作的建筑，在庭院里留下了一个爆炸装置。拆弹小组排除了险情。但如果孩子们按时到场的话，
that door was always three open and they were allowed to go to my tearing play. So they had a kick, not normal at all. Even as Geraldine Jogi around her neighborhood, I could see that the tensions from the past were still very much alive. On the left hand side. As you can see, the Union jacks. Yeah, Protestant neighborhood.
那扇门一直是大大敞开的，他们本可以去我的庭院玩耍。所以他们差点，一点也不正常。即便当杰拉丁带着我在她社区走动时，我能看到过去的紧张局势依然十分鲜明。在左手边。正如你所看到的，英国国旗。是的，新教社区。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. We have two post-ops there. We have a Protestant bus stop and a Catholic bus stop. So the people of the Protestants and Catholics, they would wait at separate bus stops, though, then they would all get on the same bus, right? But just, just, uh, interesting. Just crazy. Jeldin thinks that the walls in her community aren't doing much to stop violence. After all, every wall has a start and end point, so people who are determined can simply go around them. But she argues
是的，是的，是的。那里有两个公交车站。我们有一个新教公交车站和一个天主教公交车站。所以新教徒和天主教徒会分别在不同的公交车站等车，然后他们会坐同一辆公交车，对吧？但是，这只是，呃，很有趣。简直太疯狂了。杰拉丁认为她社区里的墙在阻止暴力方面起不到什么作用。毕竟，每一堵墙都有起点和终点，所以决心要过去的人完全可以绕过它们。但她认为
that there's also a larger symbolic reason for why the walls should be taken down. People who live near peace walls in so-called, interface communities actually face a stigma because of it. These communities tend to be the most economically deprived on the one in the interface, even though they've got the same skills. Ultimately, she says the decisions about whether the wall should stay or go need to be made by the people who live closest to them and are most directly impacted by the violence. Ian McLaughlin agrees. I can't be a top-down approach.
拆除这些墙还有一个更重大的象征意义。住在和平墙附近所谓的交界社区的人们实际上因此面临着一种污名化。这些社区往往是交界处经济最贫困的地区，尽管他们拥有相同的技能。最终，她说关于墙是留是拆的决定应该由那些住得离它们最近、受暴力直接影响最大的人来做出。伊恩·麦克劳克林表示赞同。这绝不能是一种自上而下的方法。
He knows that in a lot of neighborhoods, the idea of removing walls is unpopular. But he thinks it's possible if people move slowly and carefully. It has to be a process where people can come together and say, do you know what guys? Maybe the first step isn't to remove that structure. Maybe the first step is to take away the amount of fans. Go in stages.
他知道在许多社区，拆除墙壁的想法并不受欢迎。但他认为，如果人们缓慢而小心地行事，这是有可能的。这必须是一个让人们聚在一起并说：“你知道吗，伙计们？也许第一步不是拆除那个建筑。也许第一步是拿掉一些栅栏。”分阶段进行。
And let's see how we get along. Then you go back to a community and say, you know what? What make we do next here? That could involve, okay. If we take off layers and layers of certain break work and then you have someone to help you do, but what's entered for the communities? Is there going to be a play area created for kids? Is there going to be work opportunities for young people that take part in all those thoughts, have the command of the equation?
然后让我们看看相处得怎么样。然后你回到社区说：“你知道吗？我们接下来在这里可以做些什么？”这可能包括，好吧。如果我们一层一层地拆除某些砖墙，然后有人帮你做这件事，但对社区来说有什么好处呢？是否会为孩子们建立一个游乐区？是否会为参与其中的年轻人创造就业机会？所有这些想法都进入了方程中？
Even if it's slow, Ian wants the walls to come down. Eventually, he sees it as a moral imperative because there are new generations of kids growing up around these structures. And he wonders what ideas they're absorbing from them. I mean, kids being the most inquisitive little people are going to say, Dara, mama, why is that wall? And this community, you may well be told that wall was put there to stop Catholics attacking your home. And on the other side of the kid, a chair may be told that wall was put there to stop products and attacking your home. And on the other side of the kit, a chair may be told, oh, that wall was put there to stop
即使进展缓慢，伊恩也希望这些墙能被拆除。最终，他将其视为一种道义上的当务之急，因为有新一代的孩子在这些建筑周围长大。他想知道他们从中吸收了什么样的想法。我的意思是，孩子们作为最具好奇心的小不点，会问：“爸爸，妈妈，那堵墙是干什么用的？”在这个社区，你很可能会被告知，那堵墙是为了阻止天主教徒袭击你的家。而在另一个孩子那边，可能会被告知，那堵墙是为了阻止
products and attacking your home. And what are we doing? We're creating the seeds of sectarianism and kids for another generation. Hi, I'm Manifest itself and the generation's name. Does anybody's guess? This point hit hardest for me when I visited a guy named Danny Walsh in a Catholic enclave of East Belfast called Short Strand.
新教徒袭击你的家。而在另一个孩子那边，可能会被告知，哦，那堵墙是为了阻止新教徒袭击你的家。而我们在做什么？我们在孩子的心中播下宗派主义的种子，延续到又一代人。它会如何表现，在接下来的几代人中，谁也说不准。当我拜访东贝尔法斯特一个叫肖特斯特兰（Short Strand）的天主教飞地的一个名叫丹尼·沃什（Danny Walsh）的家伙时，这一点对我触动最深。
We stood in front of his house near a wall topped with spikes and painted with grease to prevent people from climbing it. He said it's always felt a bit gloomy knowing you can't interact with people on the other side. But it's the only neighborhood he's ever known. Do you like living here? Yeah, 100%. Like I say, I was born in the straight of No one know where else, so good neighbors, friendly community. You have kids, right? I have two boys, yeah. I'll do it. One is three and one is common too. Do you have any fears of raising them in this neighborhood?
我们站在他家门前，旁边是一堵顶部带有尖刺并涂有油脂以防止人们攀爬的墙。他说，知道自己无法与墙那头的人互动，这种感觉总是有点阴郁。但这是他唯一知道的社区。你喜欢住在这里吗？是的，百分之百。就像我说的，我在这条街出生，别无去处，所以邻居很好，社区很友善。你有孩子，对吧？我有两个男孩，是的。年龄多大？一个三岁，一个快两岁了。你在这样一个社区抚养他们会有什么恐惧吗？
You can hear kids playing football in the background just behind you there and they're all done. It's great. And there's ice cream trucks. Oh, right. Like any other neighborhood, it just happens to be a big brick wall with a fence 30 feet higher, whatever that is
你可以在背景里听到孩子们在踢足球的声音，就在你身后不远，他们都玩得很开心。这太棒了。还有冰淇淋车。哦，对。就像任何其他社区一样，只不过碰巧有一堵大砖墙，上面还有高出30英尺或者差不多的栅栏，
across the street from you. But life goes on. That's it, yeah. I was struck by just how ordinary the whole situation seemed. Until Danny pointed out that this ice cream truck never crosses over to the other side of the wall. It's the Catholic truck. The Protestants had their own.
就在你街对面。但生活还得继续。就是这样，是的。整个情况看起来如此平常，这让我感到震撼。直到丹尼指出，这辆冰淇淋车从来不会穿过墙开到另一边去。这是天主教的车。新教徒有他们自己的。
Life goes on into different worlds, so they have their own ice cream truck and we have ours. And simply because he's known this area, and they have their own at the other side of the world, too. It's really strange thing. Hey, come back! Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go After the break, I'll talk to Scott about what continues to divide Catholics and Protestants in Northern Ireland and one very funny television show that helps bring them together. So I'm now talking with Scott Gurian, who's the reporter on that piece. Hey Scott. Hey Roman. So one of the things I was thinking about when we were editing this story was this really fantastic TV show called Dairy Girls, which is set in Northern Ireland in the 1990s.
生活在不同的世界里继续，所以他们有他们自己的冰淇淋车，我们有我们的。而且仅仅因为他熟悉这个区域，而世界的那头也有他们自己的。这真的很奇怪。嘿，回来！走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走，走背景中休息过后，我将和斯科特谈谈是什么继续在北爱尔兰分裂着天主教徒和新教徒，以及一个非常搞笑的电视节目如何帮助将他们凝聚在一起。所以我现在正和斯科特·古里安（Scott Gurian）交谈，他是那篇报道的记者。嘿，斯科特。嘿，罗曼。所以当我们在剪辑这个故事时，我想到的一件事是一部非常精彩的叫《德里女孩》（Dairy Girls）的电视节目，背景设定在20世纪90年代的北爱尔兰。
And in particular, there's this scene in the show where the kind of woo-woo progressive Catholic priest is brought in to talk to high school kids, both Protestant and Catholic high school kids, about their shared humanity and what unites them. Here it is. Okay, so I want you guys to give me examples of things that Catholics and Protestants have in common and things that they don't have in common. Let's start with similarities. Aaron, why don't you get the ball rolling?
特别是，节目中有这样一个场景：那个有点崇尚神秘主义的进步派天主教神父被请来和高中生们谈话，新教和天主教的高中生都有，谈论他们共同的人性以及是什么将他们团结在一起。就是这个。好了，我需要你们给我举出天主教徒和新教徒共同点以及没有共同点的例子。我们从相似点开始。艾琳，你为什么不来抛砖引玉呢？
Okay, so we both, right? So we're all... Anything at all, a small thing even. Okay, so, right. I'll actually draw on a blank ear to be honest. Not to worry, someone else. A similarity. Yes. Protestants of British and Catholics are Irish. So that's actually a difference. Protestants of richer? Okay, so that's another difference.
好吧，所以我们都，对吧？所以我们都……随便什么都可以，哪怕是一件小事。好吧，所以，对吧。老实说，我脑子里一片空白。不用担心，换个人。一个相似点。是的。新教徒是英国人，天主教徒是爱尔兰人。所以这其实是一个不同点。新教徒更富有？好吧，所以这是另一个不同点。
And I'm not sure that's actually... I mean, is that true? I would say so. Yeah, I suppose that's fair enough. Oh. Protestants like to march and Catholics like to walk. Okay, can we just, Jenny, could you just, oh, you've already written it down, have you? Catholics watch RTE! Protestants love cleaning! Protestants are taller!
我不确定这真的是……我的意思是，这是真的吗？我会这么说。好吧，我想这倒也算合理。哦。新教徒喜欢游行，天主教徒喜欢步行。好吧，我们能，珍妮，你能不能，哦，你已经写下来了，是吗？天主教徒看RTE！新教徒喜欢打扫卫生！新教徒更高！
Catholics have more fringles. Protestants hate Abba. And we'll wrap it up there. I find this scene so funny, and one of the things that's great is that if you freeze frame, the girl has written down all the different differences that the kids have shouted out, and it says things like Protestants love soup and Catholics like statues and Protestants like flutes, and all these really funny, tiny trivial details that seem like the world to these kids.
天主教徒有更多的小刘海。新教徒讨厌阿巴乐队。我们就聊到这吧。我觉得这个场景太搞笑了，最棒的一点是，如果你定格画面，那个女孩写下了孩子们喊出的所有不同的差异，上面写着诸如“新教徒喜欢汤，天主教徒喜欢雕像，新教徒喜欢长笛”之类的话，所有这些非常搞笑、微不足道的小细节，在这些孩子眼里就像整个世界一样重要。
But if you look at the chalkboard that says similarities, it's completely blank. I can't find any similarities with each other. And it's played really for laughs, very effectively for laughs. But I think it says something really interesting, culturally about the conflict. Yeah, Roman, I think you're on to something because believe it or not, from my own reporting, I could say that all these weird little perceived differences between Catholics and Protestants aren't just things that were made up for the TV show.
但如果你看写着“相似点”的黑板，它完全是一片空白。我找不到彼此之间的任何相似之处。这纯粹是为了搞笑，而且喜剧效果非常显著。但我认为它在文化上对这场冲突表达了一些非常有趣的东西。是的，罗曼，我觉得你抓住了要领，因为信不信由你，从我自己的采访中，我可以告诉你，天主教徒和新教徒之间所有这些奇怪的、微小的微小感知差异，不仅仅是为了电视节目而捏造出来的。
Like these are things that people from the two groups really said about each other at one time and to a certain extent still do. In fact, one of the things that was on the blackboard and that clip he just played was something I actually also heard from one of the people I interviewed, Joe O'Donnell. There is an enjouque here among people who live here, and they ask, you know, well, if all of those things feel, how can you tell the difference between a Catholic and a Protestant and the stop-on to raise their eyes or closer to God?
就像这些是这两个群体的人曾经真正对彼此说过的话，而且在某种程度上现在依然在说。事实上，黑板上的内容之一，也就是你刚刚播放的那个片段中的内容，其实也是我从我采访的其中一个人——乔·奥唐纳那里听到的。这里居住的人们之间有一个内部笑话，他们会问，你知道的，好吧，如果所有这些东西都不管用，你怎么能分辨出天主教徒和新教徒，那就是停下来闭上眼睛还是更接近上帝？
It's a joke. Your silence there in that moment when you can't tell if he's telling a joke or not is so funny to me. Will you don't know what to make? I didn't know what to say. It's so far into me. I clearly didn't get the joke in the moment. But I think the point Joe is trying to make is just kind of how ridiculous this whole discussion is because, yeah, there are legitimate historical grievances, particularly on the Catholic side. So people do see a difference between Protestants and Catholics. And it's not all just based upon Protestants like Super, but in day-to-day life as you're walking down the street, it's true. You really can't tell a Protestant from a Catholic. And I don't know if that fact is really inspiring
这是一个笑话。那一刻你的沉默，当你分不清他是在开玩笑还是认真的，太搞笑了。你不知道该作何感想。我不知道该说什么。这对我来说太陌生了。我当时显然没有get到那个笑话。但我认为乔想要表达的观点是，整个讨论是多么荒谬，因为，是的，确实存在合理的历史积怨，特别是在天主教这一边。所以人们确实认为新教徒和天主教徒之间存在差异。这并不完全是基于“新教徒喜欢汤”，但在日常生活中，当你走在街上时，确实如此。你真的无法从外表上分清谁是新教徒谁是天主教徒。我不知道这个事实究竟是鼓舞人心
or really troubling because as an outsider, you see how similar these groups are and you think, well, if there are so similar, you know, maybe this can all be solved, but it really speaks to the depth in the darkness of this history that everyone is holding on to The differences the two sides have rather than their similarities But it sort of makes me wonder is there less of a conflict among the younger generations?
还是真的令人不安，因为作为一个局外人，你看到这些群体是如此相似，你会想，好吧，如果他们如此相似，你知道的，也许这一切都能解决，但这确实说明了这种历史的深度和黑暗，每个人都紧抓着双方的差异，而不是他们的相似点。但这不禁让我怀疑，年轻一代之间的冲突是不是会少一些？
Yeah, yeah, I think you know You do have this younger generation now that was born after the worst of the violence and doesn't you know Have the memories of all the the serious hatred for the other side So they might be more open to removing some of these walls in the future. And I have to give enormous credit as well to people like Ian and Keir and Geraldine who are in my piece, who work with community groups, including young people to get them, you know, to interact with each other and change their perceptions about their neighbors and hopefully bring about peace.
是的，是的，我想你知道，现在确实有这样一代年轻人，他们出生在最严重的暴力冲突之后，你知道的，他们对另一方没有那种深重的仇恨记忆。因此，他们未来可能会更愿意拆除其中一些隔离墙。我也必须对我的报道中采访的像伊恩、基尔和杰拉丁这样的人给予极高的赞誉，他们与社区团体合作，包括年轻人，让他们互相交流，改变对邻居的看法，并有望带来和平。
And, you know, all that said though, some of the progress that's been made, unfortunately, I think, could be undone depending upon what happens with Brexit. Well, that's interesting. So how does Brexit relate specifically to the situation in Northern Ireland and the generational divide? Well, first of all, I should set the scene kind of for those who haven't been following Brexit closely. I should explain that Northern Ireland has been a main sticking point in the negotiation
而且，话虽如此，尽管取得了一些进展，但遗憾的是，我认为，根据英国脱欧的发展，这些进展可能会付诸东流。嗯，这很有趣。那么，英国脱欧具体与北爱尔兰的局势以及代沟有什么关系？嗯，首先，对于那些没有密切关注英国脱欧的人，我应该大致介绍一下背景。我应该解释说，北爱尔兰一直是谈判中的一个主要症结所在
so far because here's the deal. Great Britain consists of England, Scotland and Wales, of course, and Ireland surrounded by water. But Northern Ireland is also part of the UK and it has this 300 mile land border with the Republic of Ireland, which is a member of the EU, so that raises a number of questions. If Brexit happens, in the UK's new Prime Minister Boris Johnson, says he's committed to making it happen, what then do they do with the border, and how does all that impact the Irish peace process, which as we've discussed remains fragile to begin with.
到目前为止，因为情况是这样的：当然，大不列颠由英格兰、苏格兰和威尔士组成，爱尔兰则被水包围。但北爱尔兰也是英国的一部分，它与作为欧盟成员国的爱尔兰共和国有着300英里的陆地边界，这就引发了一系列问题。如果英国脱欧发生，英国新任首相鲍里斯·约翰逊表示他致力于促其实现，那么他们将如何处理边界问题，这一切又将如何影响爱尔兰和平进程？正如我们所讨论的，这个进程本来就仍然十分脆弱。
Many Catholics would view Brexit as kind of further separating the North from the rest of Ireland, so the tensions could unfortunately flare up again. And Ian McLaughlin basically told me he thinks that, if the UK goes ahead and leaves the EU, it would heighten longstanding political differences and make it all that much harder for these peace walls to come down anytime soon.
许多天主教徒会将英国脱欧视为进一步将北部与爱尔兰其他地区隔离的做法，因此紧张局势不幸可能会再次爆发。伊恩·麦克劳克林基本上告诉我，他认为如果英国继续退出欧盟，将会加剧长期存在的政治分歧，并使这些和平隔离墙在短期内倒塌变得更加困难。
And then back to the larger question of the border between Ireland and Northern Ireland. Right now it's totally open and hardly even marked in many places. But in a Brexit scenario many people are wondering if the government would have to build an entirely new wall separating the two countries to regulate customs and immigration. No one on any side wants to see barriers or checkpoints, but we've just got a little over two months left until the Brexit deadline, and at this point there's still a ton of uncertainty. So, the result might be more walls, but in your reporting, you mentioned that the Northern
然后回到关于爱尔兰和北爱尔兰之间边界的更大问题。现在它是完全开放的，在许多地方甚至几乎没有标记。但在英国脱欧的情景下，许多人想知道政府是否必须建造一堵全新隔离墙来分隔这两个国家，以规范海关和移民。各方都不希望看到路障或检查站，但距离英国脱欧截止日期只剩下两个多月了，目前仍然存在大量的不确定性。所以，结果可能会出现更多的隔离墙，但在你的报道中，你提到北方
Irish government has set a target date for 2023 of removing all these peace walls. In light of Brexit and in light of the other issues you brought up in your reporting. Is there any progress towards meeting that goal? That's pretty soon. Yeah, unfortunately, there hasn't been much progress. That goal was first set back in 2013. They set this 10-year kind of target date, but it doesn't seem like much has changed since that time. I actually asked around and not a single person I spoke to believe there's any chance at all that this will happen. In fact, one guy said never mind 2023, the way things currently stand, it would be a miracle for all these walls to be gone by 21, 23.
爱尔兰政府已将2023年定为拆除所有这些和平隔离墙的目标日期。鉴于英国脱欧以及你在报道中提出的其他问题，朝着这个目标取得进展了吗？那挺快的。是的，不幸的是，没有取得太大进展。这个目标最早是在2013年设定的。他们设定了这样一个10年的目标日期，但从那时起似乎没有太大变化。我实际上四处打听过，我交谈过的没有一个人相信这有任何可能实现。事实上，有一个人说，别管2023年了，照目前的情况来看，到2123年这些隔离墙能全部消失简直就是个奇迹。
Well, that's grim. Yeah, and there's several factors that are working against progress. First of all, this power sharing agreement between Catholic nationalist and Protestant unionist lawmakers in Northern Ireland collapsed back in 2017, and the two sides are still kind of deadlocked. So the region has basically been without a functioning government for over two and a half years now. And you can't exactly get important things done without a government.
嗯，这太残酷了。是的，有几个因素对进展不利。首先，北爱尔兰的天主教民族主义和新教统一派议员之间的这个权力分享协议早在2017年就崩溃了，双方至今仍处于某种僵局。因此，该地区基本上已经有两年半多没有一个正常运转的政府了。没有政府，你根本无法完成重要的事情。
There's also a demographic element to the conversation, because in general terms, the Protestant community done without a government. There's also a demographic element to the conversation, because in general terms, the Protestant community is aging, they're moving out of the city while the Catholics have a higher birth rate and they could one day be in the majority. So the fear among some Protestants is that if the walls were taken down, they would be overrun by Catholics and could lose their neighborhoods and their cultural identity. So there's kind of push back from that angle. You know, everyone I spoke to, everyone told me that removing these walls is going to take time, and it's certainly not going to be easy, but you know, as you said, 2023 is just four years away,
对话中还有一个人口统计学的因素，因为总的来说，新教徒社区没有政府。对话中还有一个人口统计学的因素，因为总的来说，新教徒社区正在老龄化，他们正在迁出城市，而天主教徒的出生率更高，他们有朝一日可能会占据多数。因此，一些新教徒担心，如果隔离墙被拆除，他们会被天主教徒淹没，并可能失去他们的社区和文化认同。所以从这个角度来看有一定的阻力。你知道，我交谈过的每个人都告诉我，拆除这些隔离墙需要时间，而且肯定不容易，但是你知道，正如你所说，2023年距离现在只有四年了，
and these difficult conversations about how exactly to go about this process, you know, have in many, in many neighborhoods, these conversations have barely even begun. And then let me finally add that, you know, we're talking about 2023, but there's actually another date coming up in just a few weeks that I think is even more significant. September 9th actually marks the 50th anniversary of the construction of that very first piece wall between Falls Road and the Shank Hill. So, you know, here we are half a century later, and these supposedly temporary measures are still very much with us.
而这些关于如何具体进行这一过程的艰难对话，你知道，在许多社区中，这些对话甚至才刚刚开始。最后我要补充一点，你知道，我们正在讨论2023年，但实际上还有另一个日期将在短短几周后到来，我认为它更有意义。实际上，9月9日标志着福尔斯路和尚基尔之间第一堵和平隔离墙建设50周年。所以，你知道，半个世纪过去了，这些所谓的临时措施仍然伴随着我们。
Thank you Scott. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Scott Gourian, edited by Joe Rosenberg and Delaney Hall, mixed in tech production by Sheree Fusef, music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is our senior producer Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team is Emmett Fitzgerald, Avery Trouffleman, Chris Baroube, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. You can hear more of Scott Gourian's reporting
谢谢你，斯科特。《99%隐形》本周由斯科特·古里安制作，乔·罗斯伯格和德 Delaney Hall 编辑，混音和技术制作由谢里·富泽夫负责，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的资深制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队的其他成员还有埃姆内特·菲茨杰拉德、艾弗里·特劳夫曼、克里斯·巴鲁贝、维维安·李、索菲亚·克拉茨克以及我罗曼·马尔斯。你可以收听更多斯科特·古里安的报道
from around the world on his podcast, Far From Home, where he recently visited Chernobyl, and he documented an 11,000 mile road trip he took from London to Mongolia, in a ridiculously tiny car. It's called Far From Home. Check it out. Thanks to Don Duncan and Marcus Hunter Neil for Production Assistance and to Manina O'Pray of the International Fund for Ireland. We are a project of 91.7 K.A.O.W. in San Francisco Cisco and Produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland California 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective
来自世界各地，在他的播客《远离家园》中，他最近访问了切尔诺贝利，并记录了他从伦敦到蒙古驾驶一辆极其微小的汽车进行的一次11,000英里的公路旅行。节目名叫《远离家园》。去看看吧。感谢唐·邓肯和马库斯·亨特·尼尔提供的制作协助，以及爱尔兰国际基金会的马妮娜·奥普雷。我们是旧金山 91.7 K.A.O.W. 的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的广播街制作。《99%隐形》是来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia 成员，这是一个充满独立精神的集体
of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find mall at radiotopia.fm You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. But you can move freely between thousands of design stories at 99PI.org. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
拥有所有播客中最具创新性的节目。请在 radiotopia.fm 查找所有节目。您可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。您可以在 Twitter 上 @Roman Mars 或在 99PI org 上 @节目。我们也在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。但是您可以在 99PI.org 上在数千个设计故事之间自由浏览。来自 PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。